spargo is the definition of a prodigy
tries to get the back of the tech chase
center stage oh sh wow that forward was
god
that's it at just 16 years old spargo is
the best smash ultimate player in the
world is he gonna force it out no
sparkle hangs onto his jump response
aggressively and even more aggressively
the limit blade beam but he's still
alive yeah he's barely hanging on man
one good hit absolute for sure we'll do
it
his plays are flawless his skills are
unbelievable and despite his age and
inexperience spargo is one of the
clutches pros in the game right now
what's he gonna do with it yeah he held
on stage looking for showing the forward
toe oh he catches him on the back there
jumping that is
gonna be sparkle reverse three o wing mk
whale are you serious max are you
serious but spargo's path to the top was
different he turned smash's online arena
into his training grounds and the
greatest player in the world
into his rival he was able to make it
back but this is his last [ __ ] oh my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay guys so before we dive into fargo's
story i just must humbly request that
you like the video smash that subscribe
button and turn on notifications we're
actually really close to hitting 2
million subs and would really appreciate
if you could help us get there alright
so if you have paid any amount of
attention to smash ultimate in the past
couple years then it's
very likely that you've at least heard
of spargo and for good reason everyone
calls him he's like the most consistent
player in the game right now which is
really scary because there's a lot of
really consistent players in the game
his play style
is a lot different from most players he
just kind of like does whatever like he
he almost like plays the most reactively
of all the players i've seen like he
kind of just always has an answer to
every situation i mean he's really
really good until fairly recently though
fargo wasn't exactly on many people's
radars to the casual observer it looked
like he came out of nowhere but actually
spargo has been playing smash since he
was about nine years old attending local
tournaments in his native mexico and the
crazy thing is he was always good by the
time he was 12 years old he was
basically the unofficial best player in
his corner of mexico as he told larry
leur at the end of smash 4 i was 12
years old and i wasn't able to travel
but the best player in my region was
like top 10 in mexico like no one knows
about this but but i always beat him at
the end i was the best player in my
region i was like a
hidden boss in mexico everyone knew
about me but i've never had a chance to
to travel now historically
mexico hasn't exactly been a hotbed for
smash talent most of the top players in
smash 4 and ultimate were either
american or japanese with one glaring
exception he's going to try to go low
can he spike it he mistimes it he grabs
the left and with that fk leo defeats
tweek to be your 2019 evo champion mk
leo is one of the most dominant smash
players of all time he's had an iron
grip on ultimate since the moment it
came out coming off a streak of
dominance in smash 4 in the latter years
of that game's life too mexico wasn't
considered a top region until leo wiped
the floor with competitors from all over
the world at smash's most prestigious
tournaments and brought his countrymen
to the global stage and not even the
second and third best players from the
region could hold a candle to him leo
was the undisputed best smash ultimate
player on the planet and it didn't look
as if that was gonna change anytime soon
except there was a new challenger slowly
but steadily rising up in leo's backyard
spargo so when ultimate came out i was
able to do travel for the first time to
genesis and it was my first tournament i
placed 49 or something so yeah yeah it
was good but never had a chance to
travel spargo start was a little bit
slow when he was playing offline at
genesis 6 he got 49th at prime saga
which is another eight-year event he got
25th and at that ceo i'm talking about
you got 17th so those results are pretty
solid um but that was all before the
quarantine so just when spargo was
finally old enough to travel the global
pandemic shut down offline tournaments
all over the world now that should have
stunted his growth as a player for
years online tournaments are bad in most
games but smash arguably has it the
worst the netcode is incredibly awful
with matches so laggy at times that they
can barely be considered competitive
it's just not the kind of environment
that should turn a young up-and-coming
talent into a star but spargo's meteoric
rise began with the dreaded online era
of esports whereas most other players
saw a problem
spargo saw an opportunity oh grinding
online is good because you can play
against more players like if you only
stick to your vocals you always play the
same players but i feel like on wi-fi
you can just play different characters
and get more experience and stuff
i hope you can hear me sparkle you gotta
finish it with a finishing touch
no backyard you know what we'll take it
out we'll take it
fargo closes out the reset with a 3-0
over meister winning the lockhart series
one super good stuff from spargo man oh
man what up what a run
i'll bear strange two layers
into a cross slash zero 97.
go off stage oh dear oh dear god oh no
he's
he's not alive
okay and with that with a rather swift
decisive and no matter what character he
uh his opponent played a 6-0 coming out
from spargo and sparco is going to take
this tournament spargo grinded out
dozens of online tournaments during the
pandemic building experience he never
could have got traveling in person so
sure spargo was doing super well
but he was still living in mk leo's
shadow spargo and leo had faced off
three times in 2020 and spargo only won
once when leo was messing around with an
off-meta mid-tier character
otherwise leo looked untouchable it's
not no he has to use limit to come back
but now he has to fight without limit up
air that's it
and leia wins over spargo three to one
not only that leo had spent most of the
pandemic messing around with lower tier
characters by leth a mid-tier became his
signature pick and if the best player in
the world didn't even need the best
characters in the game to win then what
hope did anyone else have and at the
smash world tour 2021 mexican qualifier
it looked like more of the same leo
destroyed spargo in the winner's finals
recognizing that getting under that
platform kind of threatened needle there
speaking of you saw him yeah he saw him
wait man that was all patience in a
tight situation spargo just wanted to
get to the ground
give himself another opportunity but leo
paying off the pirate mithra work spargo
shook off the loss with a quick win
against meister in the losers finals and
set the stage for his run back with the
whole world watching this was his chance
to prove that he was mexico's greatest
it doesn't even matter though he hit him
on the smash four right there i'm
breaking this one up here
hit him with the smash bro up there for
sure leo
stop with the the
shenanigans bro they ain't helping
sparkles is waiting for it too if you
see where he's positioned he just kind
of like expects fargo
he could put this one away he's got his
limit to everything kind of working in
his favor at the moment leo
wow what a comeback effort
i don't know man uh fargo
yeah he's playing he's been playing
quite well i don't think he was gonna
get it and that is exactly why fargo
again perfect spacing every time takes
the tournament over mk leo in two three
one fashions
beating mk leo three to one was no small
feat and it made a lot of people take
notice of this kid who seemingly came
out of nowhere to destroy ultimate's
best player and spargo kept the momentum
oh my gosh rolling this is just a matter
of time and that's it
yeah give me a three two one she's ready
three two
one
shush
that is it folks boy we're all like that
one bro oh my god down throw oh
game five no foresight one extra frame
early oh and catching the down be out of
disadvantage fargo the king of wifi
himself is your get on my line 2021
champion congratulations to the kid
hailing from mexico one of the strongest
out there and one of the most improved
players like spargo grinded they went
through that you know what i mean and
nothing will make you tougher uh than
playing in a tough environment like that
and he played against some of the best
players his online results are insane
too he was i think he was the number one
ranked player online when we were done
there were a couple different you know
kind of data points there but i'm pretty
sure when we're all said and done he was
the big storyline coming out of it where
it's like all right you did well online
you know but what is that what does that
really mean what does that mean in the
real world though you know like does
that really translate and uh you know
clearly i gotta say if you put the hard
work in you're gonna see the results
spargo was obviously an online god
but his offline results
were a different story
spargo's return to offline play
wasn't exactly a coronation all right
what do you do here if you're spargo uh
you whittle down at this oh you died
while going from a tie for 49 to the
genesis 7 just before the pandemic to
third place at smash ultimate summit 3
is a huge jump
spargo was basically right back to
losing to leo but spargo wasn't going to
give up that easily he'd just
need to try something new for most of
the pandemic spargo had been building
his skills up with cloud but in 2021 he
decided to add one more character to his
playable arsenal shortly before offline
events came back spargo picked up pyra
and mithra as a secondary i feel like
there are some matches with cloud that
are just straight up impossible really
hard to play and i have parameters
backup when they dropped pyra and mithra
were quickly considered the new best
character in the game with high damage
speed and a great combo game piramithra
seemed insanely powerful and spargo
was there for it so when he picked up
pyro mithra it's like oh man this might
be a wrap like this kid now has like
access to the best character in the game
it fits they fit his play style so well
all this good stuff and you could see it
like immediately you could see how good
he was with those characters but between
the change of scenery and getting
comfortable with his new pick spargo had
a temporary dip in results and of course
he still had to prove that that win over
mk leo wasn't a one-time thing fearless
even in the face of this limit being
presented to himself which has to be
exhausted just for the recovery option
the
is costly my god that's a little bit of
desperation creeping in fargo don't let
the nurse be your arse enemy no way no
way
and leo steals main stage away from the
clutches of fargo by the end of 2021
spargo's lifetime record against leo was
four to 11. that's just over a 26 win
rate
leo was just too good
do you know what like the fact that his
fargo is right there trying harding
every single tournament just makes me
don't want to stop but spargo wasn't
discouraged he was dead serious about
winning everything he could offline so
much so that he enlisted the help of one
of the veterans of smash
mew2king mew2king you know is a person
who has seen it all across every single
smash title he's played competitively
not only does he have a good eye for the
game and the data involved behind it
which can really help players out but
just the mental side of it and how you
bounce back from tournament losses and
all that good stuff to have somebody
mentor you who's been around for you
know at this point mutual king's been
competing 17 years or something so
um that kind of experience in your
corner definitely helps of course no
matter how dedicated a coach someone has
it's still on the player to actually win
and spargo was about to make all of the
haters who'd said he wouldn't be able to
keep up once offline events came back
eat their words
just standing at roll distance
blocking off the stage landing the
backyard and that does it yeah wow at
smash ultimate summit four spargo
dominated his group he three wound his
way through a quarter finals match
against another mexican player chag
before he had to go up against his old
demon mk leo in the semi-finals beating
leo at a major offline tournament would
be proof that spargo was more than just
a wi-fi flash in the pan if he could
take out ultimate's best
no one would be able to stop him you
just end the game off with good air
guard hold up maybe oh goodness what a
weird angle
is amazing here just out of frame the
back air
he was able to make it back but this is
his last [ __ ] oh my god
big mix up with the cross slash have you
yet today
i think it's possible for anybody to
overtake anybody right like i think more
from a general's perspective than like
i think leo is falling off or i think
spargo is better than him now i just
definitely see it as possible and
really like himself and tweek and leo
are all in this elite classic player
that's quite a bit above you know
anybody who's ranked four or below
spargo did it he defeated ultimate's
king and he did it offline meaning that
he silenced anyone who'd ever said that
he wouldn't be able to do it when it
mattered most with leo out of the way
spargo made short work of the rest of
the tournament annihilating light 3-0 in
the grand finals
doing everything he can to say no to
that
doesn't get the forward smash does
linger below the ledge here the nair
tries to get the back of the tech chase
trying to go center stage oh sh wow that
forward was gone
that's it
he did it he got over the hump the
second place curse is shattered and a
new summit champion is crowned
congratulations to spargo the unsigned
hype has finally done it boys spargo's
days of second place finishes were a
thing of the past i wasn't nervous
versus fly to grand finals because uh
the only time i was nervous was versus
wales of winter semis and i was like if
i can
beat well then i say i can win a
tournament then and if there was anyone
out there who still thought that spargo
wasn't the real deal
they were about to be proven wrong again
collision 2022 was coming up and spargo
was out to prove that his summit triumph
wasn't a fluke now he knew that he'd
likely have to face off against mk leo
again
the difference is that this time he knew
that leo was mortal what's he gonna do
with it yeah he held on stage looking
for showing the forward toe oh he
catching with the back there jumping
that is
gonna be sparkle reverse three o wing mk
whale are you serious max are you
serious history literally made here by
mk le or by spargo taking mk leo out
from a 2-0
yes did you see him pop off that's right
spargo talk to him love seeing the kid
emote just a little bit he is human
that's right sparkle look at the camera
baby you're killing it man but just like
at summit only a week prior leo wasn't
even the final boss instead tweek beat
leo in losers and started off grand
finals with a bang to still end up
claiming the stock here nice there
baiting out the drift through the
platform or rather the fast football he
just traced him so well no jump here
he's got the firm limit it's gonna be a
z drop oh and the coverage right there
the back i think that's it i think we're
going to get we're going to a set two
max is tweaking to do it for the home
crowd already took one that was three
quick ones he's on the perfect line
tweak has been considered ultimate's
second best player for years and now
with his own convincing win over leo he
was gunning for the same crown as spargo
his 3-0 bracket reset was a statement
tweek was here to win
but spargo responded with a statement of
his own okay i mean i'm not gonna lie
bro there's just no way right
like the more you come back the more
limit he gets i'd
yeah i'd say no way at this point max is
what i would say and even more
aggressively the limit blade beam but
he's still alive yeah he's barely
hanging on man one good hit absolutely
for sure we'll do it i love that you
know it's reminiscent of like doing back
air at the ledge and waiting to see what
you do doing double back hair double f
kill right on the ledge like that is so
good but he has to zero to death or play
completely perfectly next time that's
the toughest thing but there it comes
what a perfect way to close it out
because fargo the climb hazard was so
good all day limit climb hasn't closed
in that one out amazing play from sparta
only dropping one set all day getting
3-0 by tweak woke him up a lot right
there because he he threw him right back
what a set from the kids fargo taking
down yet another tournament we all said
this this was foretold right we all said
soon it will be sparkle's time soon it
will be sparkles time guess what guys
we're in the era right now this is the
spargo era for sure
spargo represents the new era of smash
he's beaten the best players in the
world innovated his own playstyle and
did it all while playing under
conditions that would have made most
players throw in the towel he carved his
own way to the top the online era may
have been the result of the world
shutting down but for spargo it had
ironically opened the world up instead
i think he probably
got a lot of chances to level up and be
challenged and pushed in ways that he
otherwise wouldn't have if he had just
come to the occasional us major and
also just like played online against
whatever was available there but
you know again being challenged more
having access to better players and all
that online probably helped him a lot
and then he was just able to very
gracefully transition into
a lot of very strong offline
performances after leveling up as of
right now spargo hasn't placed lower
than third in an offline tournament all
that and he's still only 16 years old
spargo isn't just a prodigy he's the
future of the game he has years of
competition ahead of him and if his
skill right now is any indication of
what those years might look like
we're in for something truly
mind-blowing you know now that he gets
to go to everything offline because he's
winning all the tournaments we're just
gonna see him continue to grow to see
fargo do so well is amazing after
so many second place finishes right just
to see him finally kind of take the
crown it doesn't feel real like i
finally did it yeah
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock